did you watch last dance episodes 4 & 5
I haven't yet that I will don't tell me
what's so frustrating I know we all know
what happens don't know it does he
retired huh as you win the bet I will
get on that immediately you you really
need to I do what's interesting is and
it's gonna be the next episode spoiler
alert
Michael Jordan's dad dies yeah that's
that's why I retired murdered murdered
but when you look into it so suspect I
went down a lying down a weird rabbit
hole last night there was the rumor that
gambling debt bits Michael Jordan and he
sells millions and millions of Michael
Jordan shoes so I don't think money
would be an issue especially if there's
a bounty on his dad's head but it's just
really weird the murders there it's two
teenage kids who killed his dad who
pulled over on the side of the road in
North Carolina there's a hotel like 50
yards out why didn't stay there who
knows and these two kids are there in
prison for life for it one of the kids
says we were working for someone
they said he was shot in the chest
there's no bullet hole in his shirt they
take the evidence of the shirt someone
on the case buries the shirt in the
backyard the attorney goes the [ __ ]
board they go no it stopped it stunk in
the office oh I buried it so you dig it
up get it the [ __ ] back to forensic man
what are you doing he goes my bat
returns a shirt now there's a gun wound
in the shirt one of the kids who the one
who did murder him says he's wearing
somebody else but then his dad is the
share for that County Jesus Christ the
other kid who's on for life he he goes
this is what happened I believe him
another kid's suspect he goes so my
friend called me his best friend called
me two young black kids call me just hey
I just killed this dude I need help
hiding the body come help me so he goes
and helps the kids that killed his dad
were black yes okay so they killed him
he helped him dispose the body in the in
the swamp or whatever put it over there
and in North Carolina the maximum you
can get your your the maximum years you
can get is 10 if you're you know aiding
and abetting yes
aiding in a murder but they gave him
life so he's trying to appeal that
I don't think she had life and he was no
he's hiding a body so but they got
Michael Jordan's and be a all-star ring
off their dad and something else and
these idiots made a rap video two days
later in the ring and the other [ __ ] are
you kidding
here's what's weird though tell me this
way and you and I don't really
conspiracy thirty guys besides this
Kovacic here's the thing flattering
house shake fighters and no but the
thing is and he's right but the thing is
don't jump for president - don't trip
hey so but just kidding the weird thing
is is his dad was missing for twenty-one
days before the report on this I know I
remember it was his birthday seven days
later the family didn't reported missing
and joined us he was the lone Luffy
always disappeared on his own it's like
you might have I mean it's any other day
yeah it is it's a shame but it's just so
it's so interesting and what else
interesting in Episode five and six last
night I think that's it one two three
four five and six was uh you know Jordan
for his gambling started taking a lot of
heat in the media and he said that's one
of the reasons retired he just don't
like the negativity coming at him and I
text my with outside go dude if he
thought this was rough think about the
players today dealing with social media
and then Jay made a good point he was
yeah but today's players are a little
soft and they're very very emo like
Kevin Durant they care about people's
opinions Jordan doesn't and Kobe came up
in social media age and he didn't give a
flying [ __ ] he didn't give a flying [ __ ]
Michael Jordan Jordan address they said
gambling problem egos Garen problem is
when your children can't eat because
you're spending money I Karen I promise
you my children eat very very well I
don't I don't just I mean I don't agree
with that and you can have a problem
still be able to hide in gambling you
have so much money
yeah Steve's never stopped gambling they
still do this call huh all of them I
like you too when it with his shoe so
they wanted him to support this governor
I think in North Carolina a black
governor beating a racist white guy
later we need support for that for this
guy he's a Democrat and he goes why
would I do that Republicans buy shoes
too
Wow yeah he was like Jim Brown because
he is I never wanted to be I'm trying to
be a role model I'm not trying to in my
souls play basketball sell shoes dude
yeah that's that's his right that's it
yeah hehe Jim Brown was very critical
I watched humor Jim Brown I watched him
debate a racist governor and Jim Brown
man was marca yes he was smart and and
he was amazing in a lot of ways I mean
Jim Brown took his role very very
seriously well is that a quote when Ali
came out it was him and Muhammad Ali yes
it was him what an avoid being political
back then you know you you you were
basically a second there was much bigger
yes thing was much different than what
Jordan and you remembered you remember
Jim Brown and then remembered not being
able to vote being you know secretary
different times yeah different I don't
think that should rely on Jordans
shoulders to kind of pick Democrat
Republican I don't think it's come I
think it's I think you are allowed to
say I'm an athlete and I stay out of
that I think I think to be as great as
Jordan it was the only thing you could
do right I mean at least for him I don't
know what to I don't know what it takes
to be that great but I would imagine it
takes dedication show they've showed
like you know him getting off the bus
him going to the hotel him after games
him before games spent time with kids
with cancer just the amount of pressure
us put up in the the notoriety and the
fame I don't think there's been a leak
even close as famous as him not even
with what he had to deal with I'm I felt
I know you got a hotel and he was laying
down he's like this is the only time I
get just to feel somewhat normal yeah he
goes I stay in here all day
speaking of greatness like when you have
to be that great so Dan Gable who went
to went to the Olympics and didn't have
a point scored against him won a gold
medal beat all the Russians didn't have
a point scored against it's never been
done it's crazy
and Dan Gable that was the Olympics when
the Israeli Olympic team was a was
killed or go by it was killed by the by
the by the Palestinian been an athlete
gotta help them out there you go and Dan
Gable was so focused on his match that
when they said what did you think of the
Olympics he said or what did you think
he says a Jewish she said he said I just
did the weather seemed a little it was a
little foggy said my joints weren't they
were like and he he didn't even that was
the last thing he was thinking about
I think he was thinking about and he
said he said that was just singular
focus he was just so focused on that
that he wasn't able to you know so I
don't again I'm not gonna criticize
Michael Jordan for being that singular
about it but even drawing was like gods
exhausted meant that I was exhausted and
then they show the cameras like man
there's never been a guy like him ever
ever yeah I mean change culture from
from shoes to hip-hop I mean everything
he was the great one was the most famous
man of all time name a more famous
person the only one who might compete
Hitler was Muhammad Ali Ashley Weiss
Ashley don't think so do the clothes
right yeah Wally
Muhammad Ali twirled well even in Africa
remember you saying with Jordan yeah and
so what Ali said was everywhere you see
a light as you fly over a city they know
I know
and I think the same I think is close I
think I think Jordan even it was bigger
because basketball was big more people
can relate to that then probably
probably I would imagine I don't know
how many people in China at the time or
Russia at the time were watching
Muhammad Ali and then when when Jordan
went to Olympics in the dream team it
just changed dynamics then you know
inspired all you know now in europe in
sweden yet some of the best basketball
players in the world do you know all the
guys from europe and all that that area
that are in the NBA now yeah but he said
he this would make him look like an
[ __ ] I don't think that's fair I
don't think of him as an [ __ ] I think
of him as passionate Jordan like I think
of mezack and such a fierce competitor
and passionate yeah I must say that's
why I've seen that last night watch it
when my I told my grandma I don't use
words he make me read it maybe the next
episodes it shows him but I don't I
don't see it yet I think he did didn't
you tell me he punched and he punched
not Purdue will Purdue okay I love Steve
Kerr too is we a Purdue we punched yeah
but you know again the guys who are this
serious about winning and this
passionate you know the big thing on
them to not that anybody's gonna side
with Isaiah Thomas but you know they
hated Isaiah Thomas oh the rumor was
Jordan was I got because they you know
before before the dream team the
Olympics for the USA was all collegiate
players so they weren't they were
amateurs then go and compete with these
pros and we were getting destroyed so
then America went that ain't cool win
send our best
so they assembled the drink
so they called Jordan first the rumors
joint said all men as long as Isaiah's
not yeah what was that about no Hayden
they hated them because he had issues
with everybody magic he had issues you
know with Scotty he had issues with I
said Isaiah had issues with all of them
so they said he would mess up the
dynamics of the team so the rumor is
although George said it's not through
him and Jordan said they called me and
the first thing he says he implicated
that he goes the person you think is not
on the team the gentleman I meant what
he was I don't have to say anything I
didn't do anything so he goes he can say
whatever he wants he was what he was I
didn't say anything they brought to my
attention I saw Isaiah Thomas recently
at a party he is not much taller than me
he's not a tall guy to be that great
you know leave with those guys it's the
best point guard sighs Matt Johnson is
that right oh yeah that could oh yeah
goddamn what might a gallon I remember
people love Isaiah there's a great I do
love yeah well he's a great because he
wasn't liked as a coach of the New York
Knicks name yet
who is though that's how interesting so
they just didn't get along yes like
everyone thought I yeah John was a I
still hate him I respect this game I
don't like him and Charles Barkley was
on ESPN today and he said the thing that
made Jordan so god better than all of us
was he took everything personal yeah no
people don't take things personal he
never did it he never did another Sports
Illustrated interview after they they
put on the cover it's Michael Jordan
embarrassing basket of baseball he never
he never spoke or looking at the kids
all stammers limit his speech he let
chip this big and just what even is the
high school backing code well yeah I
should have made the team like that
remember that yeah you but Charles
Charles Barkley when they're in the
finals Charles scored 42 points is the
the NBA season MVP and joined Gossage in
MVP is I should he got that you then P
watch this and Charles goes it's the
only time I felt like I wasn't the best
basketball player on the court the only
time my career during those finals do
they up they have a story on there what
in the dream team
it was Jordan his his LA cañada players
but not like the other team those team
had magic and bird and David Robinson
they were stacked and joined had the
other team like the B team
and then went up 9 points and Matt John
started talking [ __ ] to him and he said
Angus wish I never did that cuz then
join went oh really
and they start and they said it was the
best basketball anybody's ever seen Matt
Johnson at one point threw the ball into
the stands they cuz he goes next I know
Jordan seems up by four oh my god he
goes we're talking the best of the best
he took over it was like I'm the alpha
dog he was after then he and they said
the gun the bus and tension was so high
and then magic went well wish I didn't
say that everybody started laughing it
was like that was the best game we've
ever played the greats
the best of the best I mean yeah and
Jordan it all extreme winter and Jordan
took over and then how about drawn tight
spot when he's playing against Clyde
Drexler the Trailblazers was the team
right you're playing against in the
finals and they kept comparing slide
Drexler to Jordan and joined us it
annoyed me that they even compared him
to me so what'd he do
well what'd he do he lit him up for
forty seven pleases Christ what he's
that drunken annoyed me they can beat us
he's a good player he's a great player
but he's not me and when they compared
him to me he was that to show them what
is there what is that a bed that me to
be honest that's just yes your greatness
it's crazy you forget how good is your
call it's like you are your own biggest
fan like like for real like you're just
like the idea that anybody would like he
he we were talking about how hard it is
cuz you've talked to champions and how
hard it is to especially fighters to
stay at the top heavy life everybody is
yeah everybody is you know gunning for
your position but for him it was the
only place he wanted to make sure you
knew he was the best yeah
how funny is that he said he goes my
goal is 20 years from now I want people
to say Jordan would still have dominate
and of course he would have what did you
hear what they did that their number one
pick Kwame Brown yeah so Jordan was like
this is the guy and when he was playing
for I think Charlotte he was the GM and
kalam is number one pick and Kwame came
to practice cocky join comes out to on
the court in his business clothes
there's a gear than on one pay Kane's
again I picked you
he's right beats him one-on-one and he's
like I don't know 50 something in
business a lot what beat his ass and
they said one of the reasons quanta
Brown was the bus is Jordan broke him
down I was like you're the guy
you're the number one pick this is what
you do just back them down [ __ ] Gucci
suit I got just such a month do you
y'all watch the Olympics thing cuz you
have think about it it's David Robinson
Shawn Kemp Christian Laettner you know
the best of the best
now BET Magic Johnson Larry Bird the
best of the best and they give during
the B team and he takes over do they say
hit the next 9 shots in a row once they
start talkin [ __ ] don't ya just to show
his alpha male yeah damn that's so sick
then they go into his hole Jordan like
shoo stuff how he didn't want he didn't
like Nike he wanted to sign with Adidas
and then show him in a pair of DJ's I
thought was gonna throw up they show me
an adidas and his mom's the one who's
like listen this is a new company yes
their track company but go out there
just see what they have to say they're
putting all this hard work in you owe it
to them to grab there see what they say
so they go out there and join still was
like I don't know man they give him this
pitch they signed him for the first at
the time they said it was $250,000 the
next athlete to get a shoe endorsements
making a hundred thousand so cigar I'll
take the money and his agent goes well
Nike you're in your track shoes you're
putting air in them and you're calling
them whatever Nikes well his gonna be
here Jordan and that's how that got
started really Air Jordans it's
fascinating and then the first year they
thought they they thought he was gonna
make well they said what we want to do
is make something like 3 million over
the three years in the first year they
made some like twelve eight million
dollars like just blew it out of the
water yeah he's just he's just even
little kids
he's just astonishing and I really like
Mike the commercial yeah he's just
astonishing he's a star well that'd be
like my commercial Gatorade yeah you
know they're recreating that they're
gonna redo it with in heaven I think I'm
pretty sure Zion Williams is in it which
is no I don't you know how I didn't grow
up with American sports yeah and ended
up with they were laughing at me so hard
cuz I was 23 and I was watching him play
basketball with my friends who were all
you know Irish tying he's critique in
New York no I went I said I went like
this I go I go I was like he's so good I
was just watching that aerial shots and
I was like
he's so good he looks Jordan aid the
next day that kept corn hey Who am I I
got Michael Jordan can play basketball
he's really good you know I mean I just
for me I didn't even know anything about
basketball and I was just astonished it
wasn't when they show how good he was
you're saying like content no it's a
whole different thing um but the
Charlemagne did tweet out this he was
saying how there it is Sian Williams
Jason Tatum all right all right but they
did say how impressive it is what LeBron
has been doing since 18 you know be in a
social media world and all the
negativity and all the hate he gets yet
he still performs and dominates yeah go
Charlemagne's tweet uh Jim Sharman
straight on Michael yeah yeah you'll see
it the bronze looks oh no not twenty
years old since it was 19 Thanks
it's funny see all the players don't
know everybody's neck is [ __ ] I think
his [ __ ] cuz they just live differently
and probably doing something uh there
you go would you say her steroids in the
NBA I don't know go that one can you
imagine if MJ came up in the social
media watching the media pressure Jordan
was under during that first three-peat
makes you respect to LeBron even more
for staying in his is for staying sane
his entire career it's true LeBron's
never broke he gets so much hate mm-hmm
I don't think Jordan break though not
with that mentality because the only
person close to his mentai be Kobe and
Kobe he scored 41 points with like a
hundred and three fever he had the flu
he had a flow I mean to room until
really some wall Jalen Rose went on like
I think I don't know if you but the
rumor is ya know he was hungover but
still hundred whatever yeah yeah a flu
or hungover either way it didn't say so
43 points saying you know whatever yeah
poisoned yeah his trainer said they got
a pizza my defeating this guy pizza
before a game you put in [ __ ] trash
in a Ferrari but so the game is pizza
and straight
like dude I wouldn't eat this cuz he
said like five dudes dropped it off no
one else to eat it and joint ate it and
he's the only one I got sick so it could
be there you go
alright what's he say about it scroll
rose allegedly found his way into
college party hung out with a bunch of
Indiana kids until they're eight hours
go down more hmm who knows hungover or
flu it's impressive I'll say hungover is
almost more that's right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]